back in the day you know so talking a
few hundred years ago people thought
that an interval called
the tritone was very very devilish and
and this is what it sounds like
no i'm just joking it sounds like this
what's up everybody my name is jacob
collier and this
is music theory support
[Music]
we have a question from david brown i
don't know the difference between pitch
and timbre
pitch and tombra are two very different
things
the pitch of a note is how high or low
the note is so here's a high note
that's a c sharp and the pitch is quite
high and here
that's a very low note that's an e
timbre is
the kind of texture of a note or the the
quality your note has so
i play a note right e flat and then i
sing
oh that's an e flat ah they're the same
note they're both e flat
but one has the tomb rover midi piano
and then the other is a oh it's a human
voice so both very important variables
i'd highly recommend you explore them
both
i love this question her name is rachel
chop suey
and the question is omgong like what the
hell is reharmonization
well reharmonization is when you take a
harmonization and you sort of
um shuffle it up a bit just so you know
there are infinite ways to harmonize
everything
but just by way of example let's take
the song hey jude which you probably do
know and if you don't know it's
pretty tragic i'm not gonna lie now hey
dude i think he's in an f major
so if i harmonize that melody it's gonna
go something like this
[Music]
right so when we think about
reharmonization we take that melody
and we think how else can we harmonize
this melody
this is these first two notes right
well what other chords go with the note
a this is the note a now what other
chords go with a
there's tons of them for example d whoa
that's cool it's completely different
sound so
crazy
[Music]
so he means c that's the one he meant
but what are the
what other chords go with g well like e
flat for example whoa
so suddenly we've got
[Music]
it's like what are you doing bro and
then
they all have different feelings there's
not really right and wrong it's just
what do you feel is good
what do you feel is right that rachel
is what reharmonization is here's an
excellent question from ethan high and
ethan what's up and the question
reads as follows what would you call the
second mode of the major pentatonic
scale and see it's the note c d
f g and b flat i've seen suspended doing
penciling some other terms i love this
guy i use it a lot but i'm not sure what
to call it suggestions
well this is the sound of it so i guess
that's what it's called really
this is a question from scott just now
it's a short question very simple
very important it's a what is middle c
middle c is
is the note that's kind of in the middle
of the piano kind of
kind of because you've got c you've got
c you've got c and you've got c you've
got c and you've got c
and then in the middle you've got this
one but yeah what's called c4
it's like the fourth c on the piano and
i guess
it's like the most accessible c which is
itself the most accessible
key here's a question from ralph
question
is it ever too late to learn piano
keyboard i'm about to enter my fourth
decade of existence and i told myself
this year for my learn something new
it would be piano keyboard ralph it's
never too late to learn anything in life
and i would highly recommend you learn
the piano keyboard there is bottomless
discovery and creation and storytelling
and enjoyment to be found it doesn't
matter how old you are
there's there is no cap on how relevant
music can be in one's life so i highly
recommend you do it
and i'll hold you to i'll give you a
call ralph in about two years time
next up the question from roy wall the
question goes why does music theory
sound good to our ears is it science
someone
please answer i guess first of all music
theory doesn't really sound like
anything
music theory sounds like parchment music
sounds like stuff though and i guess the
honest truth of the matter is
uh no one really knows it's a bit of a
mystery next up
here's a question from trivia mafia
what's the saddest key in music
there is no answer to this question
there's not one so objectively saddest
key some people tend to well opine that
minor chords
and major chords tend to reflect certain
moods which i think to a certain point
they do
so we take you know e flat minor versus
e flat major
one perhaps slightly brighter than the
other yeah
now i personally think what makes a
chord sad
is not necessarily whether it's major or
minor but the context within which you
hear the chord
so say i'm in a flat minor for example
sometimes i'm in a flat minor
[Music]
right if i go
say i did that most of those chords are
major chords that last chord for example
is b major
but if i go that's really sad to me
the the context of b major coming from a
flat minor is what makes that sad
first of all i have to commend this
username human equivalent
of arson and the question is uh can
someone explain the circle of fits to me
because it's gibberish
and means right now i've come to realize
uh
circle of fifths well there are 12 notes
on the piano right here they all are
and one of the best ways to display
these notes is in a circle
so this is a circle and the circle of
fifths goes c
and then it goes g and then d a e
b f that's at the bottom six o'clock
then it goes c sharp a flat e flat b
flat f c that's a circular face
[Music]
i find this a really useful resource um
because keys that are close to each
other
live in a kind of similar space and
cause that far away from each other they
have a very different
relationship but you can see some of
those patterns very clearly every note
is a fifth apart
which is also as you may have learned
earlier a fourth it's the same thing you
also say it's a circle of fourths for
all i care
here's a very good question from anthony
rice music
what's the music theory concept that you
find interesting hashtag music
hashtag music theory one music theory
concept that i find
interesting that i haven't already
mentioned swing percentage if you take
a little bit if i go
[Music]
that's really swinging that's like
really hard so there you go
there's a music theory concept that i
find interesting and you may not find it
interesting and i don't mind
here's an absolute classic question from
janet brooks
what's up janet what is the devil's
interval
and why is it so evil back in the day
you know talking a few hundred years ago
people thought that an interval the
tritone was
very very devilish and and this is what
it sounds like
no i'm just joking it sounds like this
here's another one there's another one
there's another one
the tritone by nature is not resolved at
all it's very uncomfortable to stay here
it's called a tritone because it's three
tones added together and in the usa you
would say it's a whole step but here in
the uk we see a tone a tone is this
distance so you've got tone tone and
tone three tones added together
there's a tritone going back to say you
know the the 1500s or so
there wasn't really a good use for this
interval because a lot of the music that
was written there was built out of
fourths and fifths
right the idea of doing this was
completely insane
and so it was such a dissonant sound
with no context that all people could
say it was
this must be satan this is this is the
devil speaking through music
in jazz we like dissonance and and it's
really interesting
[Music]
here's an excellent question from janet
brooks i think this is the second
question from you janet i'm glad you're
asking so many good questions
how do you change a c major chord into a
c minor chord
i've been there let me tell you i've
been there well i think we've all been
there you've got c major chord
and you just think i want this to be c
minor and it's a very very simple
equation to solve you take the e
and you weigh her down
one two three
that's a minor chord just just make that
make that third slightly flatter
put some weights on it you know give it
some luggage or something
yeah here is a more practical question
from kk
what do the piano pedals do a piano uh
has
normally three pedals the pedal on the
right which is
a bit like the sort of accelerator you
can say the gas pedal
that one uh is called the sustain pedal
and so when i play lots of notes
with no pedals pressed down they are
what's called staccato
but they're short if i put the pedal
down sustain pedal down
they sustain and when i lift the pedal
they cease sustaining that means i can
go
and all the notes ring and when i
release the pedal they all stop
it's kind of like magic so then there's
a pedal on the left of the of the three
is usually what's called a soft pedal
and what the soft pedal does
is it makes all the notes just slightly
quieter and this is good say if you have
like um
sensitive roommates or it's just very
late or you're just
not in the mood for making loud noise
now the pedal in the middle um
i know of two uses of this of this pedal
one is what's called
um the sostenuto pedal i play a chord
i hit the societal pedal and only those
notes are sustained and around those
notes i can actually still play staccato
notes
right which is kind of fun because it
means that certain notes will stay
insert notes won't sustain and you can
change that chord all the time so it's
almost like a sort of halfway sustain
pedal
where you choose which notes you would
like to sustain the other use of the
middle pedal sometimes in upright pianos
like the one that i have at home
is um the mute pedal and so i have a bit
of felt
inside my piano at home that goes when
you put the middle pedal down
and when you lift it up then it comes
off and that bit of felt it makes it
sound really really warm it's like you
put a blanket over all the where you you
literally do put a blanket between the
hammers and the strings so when you play
it goes
instead of banging and there's a really
beautiful kind of
softness about that sound excellent
question here next up from richard
jarrett blue heart what's the difference
between 3 4 and 6 8 time there are
different ways in which you can divide
time and space within music now there's
actually a lot in common between 3 four
and six eight because three four and six
eight take up the same amount of time
if you're good at maths you would've
already noticed that the main difference
between these two time signatures
is where where the emphasis is so with
three four there's an emphasis that
happens
thrice within that space one two three
one
two three and with six eight the
emphasis happens twice
waltzes right any fans of waltzes
amongst
listeners leave a comment below uh
waltzes are in 3 4 famously
[Music]
and what's a good example of eight um
there's a tune called uh my bonnie lies
over the ocean
so thank you lenny and i hope that helps
in your
rhythmic quandary here's an interesting
question from nick berry
why are the black and white keys on the
piano keyboard spread the way they are
i don't really know i'm not exactly sure
why but i guess i'd say that
all of these notes are are naturals you
say c natural d natural e natural but
you have e
flat or d flat or
f sharp these are different versions of
these natural notes and all the sharps
and flats those are the black keys
so you've got the naturals and you've
got the sharps and the flats
and the sharps and flats are always the
most interesting notes because they
really add
stuff they add color they add interest
they add motion
so it's laid out where a tonality in its
basic form is the white notes and then
the black notes are
all of the kind of tributaries that lead
out of that tonality
here's a question uh from trakdo
and the question is does music theory
matter anymore
i would say the short answer to this
question does music theory matter
anymore is
is i i don't know if it ever really
mattered i don't know if anything really
matters actually but i think that as a
musician
the more options you have to intuit
through or with the more interesting
your palette is there's absolutely
nothing to be ashamed of
of zoning into the things you like and
trying to understand them in more detail
so yeah does music theory matter anymore
sure it does
but nothing really matters so i wouldn't
take it too seriously hope you have a
good time
this is a question from joe weisenthal
the different keys
presuming the mode stay the same have
distinct characteristics
like is there any other objective
difference between
a c f sharp etc besides higher or lower
joe it's a great question the short
answer is yes every key
has a different characteristic from
every other key is one of the joys of
traversing the world of music is
changing keys at least that's you can
quote me on that that's one of my
favorite things to do
if you take a different frequency you
know take a
s
[Music]
that's a different feeling from
yeah it's different different vibe every
key is a new world and so
the more ways you have of changing key
and opening doors into new keys
the more exciting it is to be a human on
planet earth
ladies and gents that concludes this
session thank you for such brilliant
questions i hope that i've been
remotely helpful and it's been wicked
fun answering them all and it's made me
think of my feet which is great thanks
for sticking around
let's do this again sometime catch you
later